In response to this notion that Syria
has this mighty formidable army,
um,
it might be worth asking Paul this,
it took the Syrian,
the mightiest army in the Middle East
for weeks of heavy artillery shelling
and the deployment of 7,000 soldiers to
retake not a city,
but a neighborhood in a city that was
held by a few hundred rebels armed with
Kalashnikovs hunting rifles and maybe a
few pistols.
That doesn't sound to me like the
mightiest army in the Middle East.
Also,
this notion of,
of it's air defense systems,
we haven't,
we haven't hit on that point yet,
but it's been alluded to a especially by
the United States.
This is a can I just make this move?
This is a country that was invaded.
It's airspace,
was invaded three times by the Israelis
in the last 20 years and one shot was
fired against Israeli planes.
Not One plane was,
was shot down.
And remember one of those sorties
involved the destruction of a nuclear
facility.
No one even knew Bashar Al Assad was
building.
So I,
I take it very skeptically that their
air defense systems,
that their military capabilities are
quite so robust.
I quite agree with Paul on that point.
And,
and military defectors.
We'll back you up on this.
By the way,
the paper tiger argument.
Smith have a strong Syrian army is
simply ridiculous.
This is not an a national army.
This is a sectarian killing machine that
has been founded by the ads and that has
been sustained and given a soccer by the
secretary and regime.
Alex is 2 million hardcore supporters.
This is a country of 23 million plus.
How can you have a civil war between 2
million people and 18 million?
That's,
I mean the numbers don't work out.
Second thing is that this is an army
that is a conscript army,
so that means that people are forced to
serve in the army.
Those who are serving in the army are
mainly from the dispossessed.
So knee working class as Malik
described,
they would do anything to affect the
price of depiction,
as I just said,
is intolerably high.
And that is what needs to be aided
because no one is going to die for the
assads from this point on because they
understand now,
despite the propaganda and propaganda
does work,
the Syrians have 42 years of it.
It does work.
It does brainwash people.
Despite the propaganda people are
beginning to understand that a regime,
the torches children,
gang rapes,
girls have 10 by official order that
trades in the organs of prisoners is not
a regime that you want to die for.